We have now explored the data set and drawn a few histograms.
This particular quiz is not graded.
But please do follow the exercise along.
Use what your learned in lesson two about the irreducible variance to treat
the average values of the three variables as random variables and
the standard deviation as the irreducible variance int he data.
So write code to do the following.
First, draw histogram of f naught of the charged amounts.
Then in the same plot, make another histogram of f
naught plus 1 times the standard deviation of f naught,
which is another variable given in your data.
In the same plot again,
draw a histogram of f naught minus 1 times the standard deviation of f naught.
You should see something like a histogram with a error band.
Once you are done with that, click on the box here.